dr wendy how many times do you mention
your four degrees this season do you
know
can you believe i don't mention it at
all
i think people i don't think so i don't
think so you said you think people will
be happy
[Laughter]
i don't think i don't think i mentioned
it i don't know it was
i told you more one day this season
wendy the season two blow up
is real i need to start there because i
feel like that is all the comments
everywhere is
damn wendy and i think it's important
for people to remember
you filmed last season like moments
after your daughter came into the world
so i just need to put that perspective
cameras were
at my house a month and a half after
having cameron and so
now what you guys are seeing is like the
wendy of before having a baby like
now i can actually sit down for three
hours and get it you know melted
into the scalp so this is that wendy oh
that's good
i'm giving rich auntie vibes you change
anything up
specifically after seeing yourself on tv
that you went
maybe i don't wear things like that
again maybe my hair doesn't look like
that again bryce i have a list
i have a list of no don't you ever don't
you ever do that though i like that
i don't even know if i can ever watch
season five again
because i i don't know if i could
stomach it i'm like girl
in my head i thought you know a few
people gonna watch the show
so didn't know it was millions
had no idea so here i am
but yes i made i made a few changes what
would you say the biggest difference was
between
season five wendy and season six wendy
who were about to see
i think season five wendy was just a bit
unsure and i think season six wendy came
into a more
confident of okay this is what i know
you know i've been around these women
this is you know what i can expect from
them
and that was the big difference for me
but it's so funny because
even with that mindset i got blindsided
in season six even though i came in
saying okay i got this you know i sort
of know where i can
bucket people i i was still blindsided i
mean i think i started saying in the
trailer
um i opened up by saying you know you
never know who you can trust
one thing you learn about living in
potomac
is a town of smoking mirrors
you never know who you can trust and
that is really interesting for me but
then
on the reverse on the light-hearted side
you never know
who can be your friend too there's
people who i didn't think i would be
besties with who i'm besties with and
there's people who i thought i'll be
besties without not
you need to know who's friend or foe
well let's unpack that because i do
think some of those um you know it's a
chess game a bit and
yeah you just move around the board i
think maybe karen and gisele
moved around your board um from what i
can pick up on
we know gisele brings up these eddie
rumors and i will put that in air quotes
because we don't know what the hell they
are so when are we going to talk about
the eddie rumors what do you want fans
to know about that situation headed into
this season
yeah so for me you know
i am not immune to the fact that we are
public figures right
this is not a woe is me conversation
when you're a public figure people are
gonna talk about you people gonna lie
about you and
it is what it is and i'm okay with that
i know what i signed up for
but in the same token there is for me a
level of expectation that
i thought we had within our circle
especially when it's a salacious blog
that has also spread
vicious rumors about her and her family
this doesn't make any sense to me
because you are
repeating a lie that if
i wanted to i could repeat the same
thing about you or
anyone here because that's what they do
and don't get me wrong like i'm not mad
at
the blogs everyone has to eat do you you
know but
amongst your you know do you i'm not mad
at it because we know our truth and you
know
i'm confident my marriage it doesn't
matter but in the same token you have a
level of expectation from your friends
and you don't think that your friends
will ever give life to a lie
if anything they will quail it because
they're your friends
so that's what was really interesting
this year
was for you for me to see how
people handle your family you know
do you feel like this was a plot brought
against you like a premeditated
thing talk to me about kind of how it
comes oh man that's a great question
do i think now that i played back a lot
of stuff
yes i do think it was premeditated
and i also know that you know certain
individuals on this show
have a pattern in the practice of
attacking people's families
that's what they do that's what they get
off on and
you know again if that's what you do do
you
but don't do that with the osepho group
i don't play
and i say that very clear do not play
with my husband's name
what you're not going to do is you're
not going to play with my husband's name
i think that this crew quickly learned
that i have what i call my sacred for
that's my husband and my three kids talk
about my wigs my clothes
anything you want to child just talk
about me
but don't talk about a man who is not
just a good husband
but a good father and whose only crime
is supporting me to be on this platform
don't do that because i will drag you
how did eddie handle being put in the
center of what seems like the big drama
of the season
it's not good i wish i had
eddie's only concern was are you okay
baby like that's all he cared about
we're going on 10 years of marriage i
didn't think i could love him more but
just how he has been like
don't worry about it leave this alone
like it doesn't matter
and just have to just be such a
gentleman because there were times where
i wanted to get dirty and just
attack back and eddie said don't do that
you're better than that and that shows
me the type of man i married so
it's been a hard experience but i have
grown from it in such an amazing way we
hear you in the trailer
promised to quote i will light your ass
up
believe that's pointed toward gisele do
you make good on that threat
you guys have to sing but what you have
to understand
from the professor is when i light your
ass up
it can be with my words it doesn't have
to be light your ass up in the way
people
think that it means because i am a
master
and a wordsworth you tell gisele in the
trailer i see you for everything
everybody ever said that you were
which quite the line making good on your
statement there that you are a wordsmith
um but what did you mean by that why did
you have to say that to her
you know coming into this and even while
i was in it
season five i had so many people my ear
telling me you know this about her or
watch out about her but
i am an individual i stand on my own i'm
one of those people that i judge you
based on what you give
and this season what she showed me was
everything that people said about her
both on
and off camera is true
everything is true and i wanted to let
her know that i see her for exactly
what and who she is the wool has been
pulled
off of my eyes like i know who you are
i've called your heart
and i will deal with you based on the
card i have read you to be
safe to say she is the person who uh
disappointed you the most
this season uh yeah i
i would i would say she did i would say
she did but that's because
i was wrongful and given her high
expectations
but that's okay now i know you also make
a mention of wanting to cut these mother
effing cameras
i love the oration these mother cameras
i think that you know and this may be
breaking a little bit fourth wall here i
think that sometimes
people forget that this is the real
world right so
don't think you're going to try to talk
about my family
under the safety blanket of saying oh no
no no
this is just for a show no this is real
life
i understand that she has made it a
pattern
to have fake relationships so
it's okay if people attack that my
marriage is real
this is not for tv my marriage is real
i take my vows seriously my vows are
sacred it's a sacrament
and so don't play with that don't play
with me
and don't play with my husband so forget
the cameras i'm talking to you in real
life
and i want to make that very clear these
other people may let people play with
their relationships
don't play with mine well how do you
feel about gizedel today i feel like
you've
kind of said your piece i can pick up
the in-between but i i noticed
you know she unfollowed you during all
this mess
you still follow her i mean if someone
read me and drag me for filth
the way i did her i would unfollow them
too
i'm not mad she shouldn't follow me
imagine me saying what i said to her and
she still follows me
so yeah she did the right thing but why
do you still follow her
imagine me typing in her name to hit on
follow
you're not you can't even be bothered
with that energy got it yeah
maybe eventually sometime in the future
when i have time but right now i am too
booked and busy
to type her name in my phone but thank
you for giving me the honor of typing my
name
in your phone
[Laughter]
uh on the flip side of giselle
disappointing you did anybody surprise
you in a good way
in season six that would have to go to
karen
karen did karen karen gets that award
i spoke to her yesterday and she
basically said how dare you keep coming
for our husbands when you don't have one
first return served
i'm just saying don't touch anything
that you don't bring to the tape
how about that harry yet
period come on karen no
karen really this and i want you guys to
see it i don't want to give it away but
when i tell you
karen is definitely like she gets the
crown
like absolutely she she
did what i would have expected
some others to do okay that is
i don't think it's a full 180 because
you were kind of like
growing as the season went on but it's
like a 90 degree shift probably it is
it is and i and i salute her for that
well you're no longer the new girl we
have mia
in this group so talk to me about one
not being the new girl anymore and to
what mia's like what does she bring
to the dynamic not being a new girl is
good
and mia is is different i say it
and the reason i say that because you
know when you're in a group of
other women you sort of think we have
someone that represents every
personality type but then in comes me
and you're like wait
she's different she brings something
different to
our group so she definitely does that
and she
brings some um salad tossing skills to
the group
some salad sauces skills amongst many
other skills that you guys did not privy
to
which surprised me i had a few moments i
was like
well even just that salitas oh like
that's you and the dragon
i don't know how i always end up
screaming i don't know why
like i need to like calm it down no
please don't obviously with mia entering
we saw the exit of monique which
not a shock i think to most people
judging by how the reunion
played out how do you feel about monique
stepping away from this group and did it
change the dynamic for the better i wish
her well
and i wish her happiness and all that
she does in the future
and that's the bite
um well we i feel like we've talked a
lot of the mess is there anything that
you're really
excited for the fans to experience or to
relive yourself
i think this season my mommy hat is just
to see how much my kids have grown
and even with their growth not just
getting older
we actually have some tough
conversations and i'm interested
for you know the viewers to see that
just you know me talking to my kids
about things that are
serious and it hasn't really dawned on
me that my kids are the age where they
know what mommy does
and some of what mommy does is you know
tough
and so we have those conversations so um
the way we resolved it and the way we
talk through it eddie and i without kids
is just something that will always have
a place in my heart
i love it it's a meaningful
conversations but also the world's best
home movies
yeah forever your your career was a
a big focus of the second half of season
five and deciding what you wanted to do
um have you stopped teaching you know
i have not stopped teaching the pandemic
hit
and you know educators are essential
workers
and i just didn't feel as though leaving
my job
in this moment was best for my students
you know um
the world was going up in flames and for
a lot of students just having that
normalcy of
school kept them going and
i just didn't think it was the best time
for me to leave
with the pandemic yeah i think the
pandemic
put a lot of things into perspective for
a lot of people
um i wonder you know we also learned
about eddie's family and their feelings
toward
your marriage has there been any
positive motion on that or will we see
any
new information about that in season six
you guys will see some new information
about that
in season six a little bit but we
definitely touch upon it
all right my last question is more
social media you were hanging out with
luanne
shannon gina people went nuts
yes can you tell me what you were doing
no
but you guys are you guys gonna see it
we'll let it out
it's not what people have said it is
i'll say that much
you